Welcome to the session of Decoding Cancer's
Complex
Ecosystem.
My name is Hoifung Poon. I'm from Microsoft Research.
Very excited to welcome you to this session.
And so, as we all know,
cancer, one of the really primary challenge is that it's
very robust, right?
And so the first generation
chemotherapy tried to target mitosis, tried to kill dividing
cells. Toxicity is high, and efficacy is low.
Then came the genomic revolution and the targeted therapy,
leading to the notion of precision medicine and precision health.
But still, cancer has the blessing on natural selection, and
often find out ways to compensate, to escape, to
actually get roaring back, right? So leading to all the relapse and so forth.
Immune system is one health system that also
have natural selection on its side.
So, immunotherapy is a really promising direction
for taming cancer once and for all, right?
So indeed, we have seen, obviously, many of you know way better than I do, right,
that when immunotherapy works, oftentimes the response is much more
durable. The challenge still is that right now,
a lot of the immunotherapy is still a blunt instrument, right?
So checkpoint just released the brake, and the overall
response rate is still far too low.
And
the current companion like PD-L1s and TMB, they are not
that good at actually stratifying patients, right?
And so the question is how can we actually go much, much better
and to do much, much more precise stratification of the patient?
Now, tumor microenvironment is
really one kind of 80/20
ways to actually start to unraveling a lot of those kind of
secrets about why can the
patient respond or not responding, right?
And when we look at the tumor microenvironment, it's a very complex
ecosystem of immune cell, tumor cells, stromal elements, and so forth.
So there is lots and lots of clones and
heterogeneity,
and also there is a lot of temporal complexity, right?
So the tumor microenvironment constantly
changing in respond to immuno pressure, in respond to treatment
pressure, right? So
understanding this kind of tumor microenvironment grammar
thereby could really start to shed light on
how we actually can understand the cancer
response, treatment response, and eventually figure out ways
to actually
make immuno-oncology much more precise.
So, the goal for this session is try to overview
all this complexity, right, from mechanical
to temporal complexity,
and then try to discuss a little bit about how artificial intelligence
can potentially provide us some of the very powerful new tools,
equip a human expert with some of the new capability to try to
uncover this kind of tumor microenvironment grammar.
So, I'm very excited to have the first speaker
of this session, Dr.
Ken Pienta, who lead the Cancer Ecology
Center at Johns Hopkins.
So he will basically introduce this eco-evolutionary
lens for understanding the tumor microenvironment.
Now, unfortunately, Dr. Pienta has a family emergency,
so he couldn't actually come here.
So he actually recorded a video, so I will play that video
now.
So,
again, apology that we cannot do a live Q&A with Dr.
Pienta here, but he is more than
happy to communicate with you guys offline, right?
So after Dr. Pienta give his talk introducing
the
tumor microenvironment
ecosystem, I will talk a little bit about how AI might be able
to help decode that tumor microenvironment grammar.
So that will be the plan for the session.
So now, let's play the video from Dr. Pienta.
Hello, everyone, and thank you so much for
allowing me to present this talk to you by
video conference. I'm very sorry that I can't be there
today with you,
but I really appreciate your indulgence in letting
me present to you virtually. I'm going to give you a
talk today about tracing the eco-evolutionary path of
tumors to understand cancer, but really what I'm trying to
do is set you up for the next talk
by your chairman. So here we go.
I have really no relevant disclosures to this
discussion except to say that I'm a professor
at Johns Hopkins University, and none of the
entities I consult for are
relevant to this talk.
I wanted to say welcome from the Cancer Ecology Center at
Johns Hopkins, where we're harnessing ecology and
evolution to redefine cancer risk detection
and treatment. The issue we have is that
20 million people a year around the world
are diagnosed with cancer. 10 million of
those patients are cured with local therapy, but 10 million
patients progress with metastatic and therapy-resistant disease and
ultimately die of this
disease.What is this
idea of convergent evolution and how do these
different cancers, all of which start independently in different
people,
converge to this lethal phenotype?
Well, convergent evolution is the independent evolution of
similar features in separate species and, or at
different periods of time. It leads to analogous structures that have
similar form or function but were not present in the last
common ancestor.
Good examples of this are eyes, teeth, wings and
especially stress response, which is important for us here today.
The convergent lethal phenotype of cancer leads
to 10 million deaths per year worldwide.
What is that convergent lethal phenotype?
Well, number one is metastasis. Cancer spreads from the primary
tumor to other parts of the body and the second
part of the lethal phenotype is therapy resistance.
Cancer is resistant to all known forms of systemic treatment
even before it's been exposed to those treatments.
So we try to look at this problem a little differently.
Generally, we think of cancer as a disease of mutations,
but cancer is no more a disease of cells than a traffic jam is a
disease of cars. A lifetime study of the internal
combustion engine would not help anyone understand our traffic
problems and tumors are the same way.
This was a very famous quote by David Smithers from
1962.
So what is cancer? Well, cancer is a disease of
uncontrolled proliferation by transformed
cells subject to evolution by natural selection.
We think about this because nothing in biology makes sense
except in light of evolution.
But nothing in evolution makes sense except in light of
ecology.
Evolution is change in heritable variation over
generations,
but ecology are the external forces that influence
adaptation.
Evolution acts upon phenotype, not genotype.
The evolution that we observe in each patient is a result of cellular
adaptation to those changing ecological forces,
i.e. the tumor microenvironment and the patient macro environment,
that cells that adopt a successful phenotype
outcompete those with a less optimal phenotype.
So our challenge is to integrate evolutionary principles to
improve patient care.
Remember the ecology. What selective forces are at play in a
patient? How do they change over time and space?
What adaptive cellular phenotypes are selected for?
With intervention, how do we change the ecology
of the adaptive landscape of the tumor?
And don't forget, treatment kills more than just cancer cells.
So what is an ecosystem? An ecosystem as defined by
Eugene Odum in the '30s is that any unit that includes all
the organisms, i.e. the community in a given area
interacting with the physical environment so that a flow of energy
leads to defined trophic structure, biodiversity and
material cycles. Ecosystems do not exist
independently, but interact in a complex web of
ecological relationships connecting all ecosystems
to make up the biosphere.
Way back in 2008 now, we first defined tumors as
ecosystems, that cancer cells as a species coexist in
a complex habitat with other host cells.
These cells interacting with their habitat create an ecosystem,
and this ecosystem in turn exists
within a larger environment. The host patient is
the
tumor's biosphere.
And we created these tables that everybody's now familiar with
looking at how we can think about
man in a ecosystem like living on the land with
cancer cell, living on the extracellular matrix,
interacting with all organisms as a man, all cells with
cancer. Our community is, for us, an
ecosystem, whether we live in a city or a farm.
The cancer cell community is the
microenvironment, creating meta communities,
metastases and living within the host
biosphere or the patient.
Cancer has several strategies to evolve traits in response
to stress that it's constantly
feeling in response to how the tumor
microenvironment is changing.
And these strategies we're going to talk more about, but they include
tumor cell heterogeneity, proliferative quiescence,
evolutionary triage, and self genetic modification.
But the bottom line is that cancer creates a new
ecosystem that now we refer to as the tumor
microenvironment. We need to understand how, we need
to understand how to disrupt this process because remember,
it's easier to drain the swamp than swat a billion mosquitoes
one at a time.
And cancer cells are actually ecologic engineers, and
there's two kinds of ecological engineers that
result in niche construction. Allogeneic
engineers modify environments by mechanically changing
materials from one form to another.
Think about beavers that construct dams.
Autogenic engineers modify environments by changing
themselves. Oak trees, as they grow, provide more and more
living space for various birds and small
mammals.Cancer
is both an allogenic and autogenic
engineer. Think about prostate cancer modifying the bone
matrix, and the growing cancer alters the environment.
Cancer creates its own beaver pond, attracting new
species like tumor-associated macrophages and
cancer-associated fibroblasts.
Does this engineering affect genetic evolution, causing an increased
rate of clonal selection?
Well, if you look at ecological inheritance in increasing
the rate of clonal selection, a feedback relationship
between natural selection and niche construction, when
organisms affect their environment, that change can cause
a shift in what traits are being naturally selected for.
The effect of niche construction is especially pronounced in
situations where environmental alterations persist for
several generations, introducing the evolutionary
role of ecological inheritance.
One example of this
on Earth are yam cultivators in West Africa.
They cut clearings in forests to grow crops, but that resulted in
much standing water, which attracted mosquitoes and increased the rate of malaria.
This caused a modification to the selection pressure for the sickle
cell allele that protects against malaria.
So does the cancer swamp increase the rate of clonal
selection? Do we see that the rate of intrinsic
genetic instability changes due to
ecological inheritance?
So let me run you through a few examples of how the cancer
swamp increases or accelerates clonal selection.
Gatenby and Gillies pointed out what's called the breeder's
equation applied to somatic evolution, where they showed that
harsh TME conditions like hypoxia, acidosis,
and a heterogeneous extracellular matrix
creates steep fitness gradients.
Alvarez and colleagues pointed out that if you looked at in
vitro versus in vivo,
clonal selection through barcoding, that there were
about 17,000 stable barcodes in vitro, but if
you
find those in tumors, there was a 73%
reduction in clonal complexity versus the starting population
and the 300 times expansion of the top clone.
There have been, again, four converging mechanisms that
have been documented. The steep
fitness gradients, for example, through the
hypoxia, immune-mediated pruning,
acidosis-driven mutagenesis, and positive
feedback loops because selected clones remodel the tumor
microenvironment to entrench their advantage.
So environmental stress can drive monoclonal
dominance. You see this in even precancerous
lesions, as shown by Zhang et al.,
where
they demonstrated a polyclonal lesion
with multiple completing clones,
selection pressure through the tumor microenvironment
leading to monoclonal dominance.
So in summary, the swamp does drive selection, and there have been
multiple examples of this across time.
And this is why it's so important to think about how we can model this,
as you'll see in the next talk. The tumor microenvironment is not
merely a bystander. It is a primary engine of
cancer evolution.
So I want to switch gears a little bit
and bring this home with thinking about why
is lethal cancer lethal? Why do we die
from cancer? This is a patient
that died
from prostate cancer, had all these lesions in their liver,
but they had normal liver function.
People don't die in general of
organ dysfunction because the cancer
metastases grow and overtake that organ.
The tumor microenvironment kills us.
At death,
we estimate that a kilogram of tumor is lethal for
a patient.
But that kilogram of tumor is spread out across the patient in
metastases. And that kilogram
represents one to two trillion cancer cells
of the total of 50 trillion cells in the human body.
It's not about cancer cell mass. We need to understand the
context within cancer occurring.
That context is the human patient host.
And so I want to
remind you that cancer has no negative
feedback loop. As long as it has enough energy to
grow, it doesn't turn off like a normal cell does.
So without a negative feedback loop, the healthy pond
devolves into a swamp.
Why do we die from cancer? Cancer poisons the biosphere
of the patient,
through cachexia syndrome, through
thrombotic syndromes, through skeletal pain, through
respiratory failure, and
the common theme here is all of these
are a result of cytokine overproduction.
And we call this cytokine overproduction
the miasma of cancer. MiasmaWhat a great
word. It's a highly unpleasant or unhealthy smell of
vapor. And so when you think about swamp gas, we
all have heard the stories of fires in the swamp lighting because
of flammable ecologic swamp
gas. But it's really methane from
dying algae and other fermentation.
But lethal cancer swamp gas is a result of
many cytokines leading to these different syndromes.
So again, we actually published this almost
20 years ago now, looking at the different
cytokines that
contribute to
what we call cancer swamp gas.
IL-6,
produced by macrophages, T cells, muscle cells, osteoblasts,
adipocytes, and cancer cells.
TNF alpha, otherwise known as cachexin.
Look at all these cells that make TNF alpha.
Cancer cells barely make this list.
It's the cells of the tumor microenvironment.
Matrix metalloproteinases made by macrophages and cancer
cells. And all these cytokines
lead to things like the cachexia syndrome, where
the cells are released from the tumor
microenvironment, causing
lipolysis of fat and muscle wasting, et
cetera.
So
what I want to leave you with here is this idea that the
cancer swamp, i.e. the tumor
microenvironment, poisons the patient.
That's why we need to understand and be able to intervene in this better.
So our challenge is integrating evolutionary ecology
principles to improve patient care.
In the clinic, if we consider the ecology with treatment type and
timing, maybe we can exploit it to attain tumor
control and perhaps eradication.
At the bench, let's move beyond mutation and epigenetic
silencing and think about what adaptive
phenotypes are targetable and manipulatable.
We published a recent paper on this
last year, which I urge you to take a look at, where we
summarize this, "Defeating lethal cancer: Interrupting the
ecological and evolutionary base of death from malignancy" in CA,
written with my colleague Sarah Amend, as well as a patient, Pat
Gooden.
So there are many ecological evolutionary paths to
evolutionary rescue following therapy,
meaning resistance recurrence. Selection acts on heritable
phenotype, not on genotype. What are the adaptive strategies at
play, and how do you shift the selective pressure?
So there's phenotypic heterogeneity.
Among the heterogeneous population, there already exists a clone that has a
trait to confer resistance, but it has to be picked.
It has to have a pressure that allows it to flourish, like
chemotherapy. And if a cell happens to have a drug efflux
pump, it's going to be the one selected for.
Evolutionary triage. Cells with better, i.e.
a more adaptive phenotypic traits, are selected
over those that are less fit, though not necessarily
absent adaptive trait. Darwin's
finches, for example, are a great example of this.
In a tumor treated with anti-androgens, over time, cancer
cells upregulate the number of ARs are more
adaptive.
Epigenetic plasticity. The adaptive trait that is selected
for is the cell's capacity to alter its phenotype in
response to its environment. Good example, cancer
cells that downregulate
presenting MHCs.
And of course, dormancy. The adaptive trait that is selected for is dormancy.
Cancer cells are only susceptible to anti-cancer
therapy if they are undergoing cell division.
So here's an example of a non-proliferative dormant
cancer cell sitting in the bone of a patient.
So these eco-evolutionary strategies can
be potentially adapted to treat
cancer. And we,
and along with many others, are thinking about how to do this
in the clinic
right now and will continue to develop these,
especially if we can adopt better
models of the tumor microenvironment.
Cancer ecology is necessary to understand
lethal cancer all the way from
the
selection from a precancerous lesion
to the metastatic therapy-resistant
phenotype.
So thank you for listening from the Cancer
Ecology Center group, and I wish I was there to
answer questions in person. Thank you very much.
So once again,
apologies
that Dr. Pienta cannot come here due to a family emergency,
but he will be really keen to
interact with you offline. So next,
I would build on top of what Dr. Pienta talked about, the
complexity in the tumor microenvironment and the cancer
progression and
resistance,
and then talk a little bit about how the confluence of digital transformation
and AI revolution could potentially provide us with new
tools, new capability to do this. So before I dive into the
detailI would just give you a little bit of my background
to set up the context for myself and this talk.
So I actually come from a straight computer science background.
Started my PhD in machine learning NLP two decades ago,
back when AI was actually in the last ice age.
So never imagined AI could be so hot one day.
And then after PhD,
I joined Microsoft Research, which coincided with the 10-year anniversary of Human
Genome Project. At that time, I didn't know how hard biomed and health is,
so got really excited and really decided to start
looking into whether AI can help precision health.
I was hired as an AI researcher, but told my boss I want to work on cancer.
Miraculously, he didn't fire me on the spot.
So here are basically a little bit of a decade and a
half of the battle scar in learning.
Actually, often thanks to a lot of our collaborators, some of them sitting in the
audience,
and actually teaching me and educating me.
So really looking forward to picking all of you guys' brain.
So I have a few speaking and advisory gig.
And so as
we all know, right,
an immunotherapy is really a very promising direction
by mobilizing the immune system, which are
naturally equipped with natural selection to really
counter the sub-cancer robustness.
But right now, even the best-in-class of immunotherapy are still far too
low response rate, right? And so the question is
that what can AI do? So here I would basically summarize
metaphorically,
on the war on cancer, AI potentially can equip us with
three new capabilities.
So the first one is a microscope. A new microscope.
So when you think about one of the really exciting prospect
of studying those tumor microenvironments and so forth,
is that there is lots and lots of new modality of data coming in, right?
So starting from multi-omics and also nowadays with a lot of
high-content imaging like digital pathology, spatial omics and so forth.
But the pattern hidden inside those
data is very, very complex. And so here, AI can
potentially empower human expert to see much better, right?
Another new capability is really a crystal ball, right?
So Dr. Pienta talk about how we need to
think about how cancer is essentially in a temporal
longitudinal journey, right? So just containing, putting cancer
in remission is far from being enough, right?
And so how can we actually understand the whole evolution
trajectory? So here, AI can potentially allow us to start to be able
to model extremely high dimension, extremely long
timescale
dynamics. And finally, AI can also give us a
wind tunnel. Right? So by start to
allow us to start simulating a lot of those kind of experiment
and hypothesis generation and testing, right?
Because one of the fundamental limitation in biomedicine is
that making every single step forward is very expensive, very
time-consuming. So the more we can actually build up
the model for these processes and be able to
actually do a lot of groundwork in the computation, the more
potential we can speed up this progress.
So,
in a nutshell, if you think about the entire technical program
that we have been looking into using AI to advance the precision health,
right, is you can sum it up as learning the language of a patient.
So, for example, thinking about a patient journey.
Starting from, you typically have a non-invasive
radiology modality like CT, MIs and so forth.
Then with biopsy resection, you start to get digital pathology, multi-omics, and so
on. Each modality is trying to tell you something about the patient,
but if we don't understand the language, then they just sound like gobbledygook,
right? On the other hand, if we can start making some progress to understand
mastering those languages, then we can start to construct this
virtual patient, a world model that as a digital twin, to start
being able to forecast disease progression and treatment response.
So obviously, the trillion-dollar question is, can AI deliver?
So there has been obviously lots of hype, lots of skepticism,
right? And I personally find it quite useful to think about gen AI
application as spanning a spectrum from what I will loosely call
productivity gain, all the way to creativity gain, right?
And
basically from automating chores, mundane
chores on the left-hand side, to all the way automating discovery.
And
many of you have heard about the Amara's law, right?
It basically observed that oftentimes when technology disruption happen,
at the beginning, we often overestimate the short-term progress, and that's
actually often lead to the hypes, right?
So, for example, we are still very far away from actually
attaining the moonshot on the right-hand side.
Even though we are already getting some pretty promising direction.
And on the other hand, we can also
underestimate the long-term progress, even though major transformation
already happened. And right now in biomedicine,
the major transformation already happening on the
left-hand side, on the productivity gain.
So in this talk, I will essentially start by
focusing on this overarching
frontier area, which is
AI can enable medical scientists to begin to simulate
clinical trials and
towards building a virtual patient, right?
And
we will start with the productivity gain to show you some of the extremely
low-hanging fruit that arguably already ready today or even yesterday.
And then go all the way to the right-hand side, the moonshot, where
we are far from actually conquering the moonshot, but there are several
promising directions.And so many of you
know better than I do, right? So medical discovery basically advances one clinical
trial at a time. This process is extremely manual, very
inefficient.
A single phase III trial can take years to execute, often costs more than
$100 million. And
what we actually do is to actually collaborate with
Providence, some of the folks sitting in the front row, to
build this
AI called TrialScope that can enable medical scientists,
like the Providence researchers, to
utilize the real-world patient journey, and then simulate clinical
trial virtually.
So we demonstrate that this kind of virtual trial can be just as accurate
as a real trial by comparing to the gold standard
trial for marquee cancer treatments.
For example, the KEYNOTE-10. So many of you know that was one of the original
trials for Keytruda, one of the best in cancer
immunotherapy. Now, obviously, by doing this kind of
simulation, we can do it much cheaper and faster.
Now, of course, I'm not advocating actually that RCT will be going
away anytime soon. But what this actually demonstrates to you is
that the real-world patient journey has lots of
valuable information, and also AI now finally gets to a
stage to begin to glean that information
now. And
one of the prerequisite conditions, obviously, is the rapid digitization
in biomedicine. So starting from genomic sequencing,
then arrived the electronic medical record.
So every day, there are literally billions and billions of data points
documenting a patient journey from diagnosis to treatment to outcome,
exactly the kind of journey that you study in clinical trial.
Right now, these data are basically primarily used for billing and
operation, and then get locked up in the attics.
But what if we can actually take those
kind of data readily available, and then using AI to
unlock all the stories that all those patient journeys are trying
to tell us?
So this could become effectively a population scale free lunch.
So
one of the challenges, obviously, is that a lot of these data are highly
unstructured. So for example, cancer patients may have hundreds
of clinical notes. But AI
have already advanced to such a state that they can enable scientists
to structure this information with high accuracy
and at scale.
So every year there are 20 million new cancer patients.
Traditionally, you will hire abstractor, registrar,
curators, and so forth. And each cancer patient could
take hours and cost you hundreds of dollars to just pull out that basic information
from those giant haystacks of clinical notes.
Now, with frontier AI-powered universal abstraction, you can do that in seconds and
cost you a few cents.
So what that means is that at Providence, for example, with our collaborators,
we basically have this
every night, when the data get back up from the live
Epic system to the data lake.
The TrialScope AI agent wakes up at 1:00 a.m., so basically
processes all the incoming notes and extracts all these fine-grain
medical events. And then you can basically tally
precisely the window of opportunity when basically a
patient satisfies all the eligibility criteria and right before
the first disqualifying event happens.
So that window of opportunity for oncology, for example, obviously often
is very short. But now actually the technology is already
here to be able to do this kind of twenty-four-seven monitoring.
And what this means is that not just empowering
clinical trial matching one step, but actually you can
start to rethink the entire clinical trial process, starting from feasibility,
site selections, and screenings, and so forth.
You can also use this to, A,
assist your clinical trial design.
For example, given a particular criteria, how many
patients might be eligible? What if you change a particular
criteria? How many patients? How would that change the number of
eligibility? Right now, a lot of this are just wild guess.
But now you can pretty much tell precisely at every
single moment in the history how many patients might fit your criteria.
And you can change your criteria, and then a second later, get all the
statistics. And then you can also start to look into external
control, paramedic trials, and electronic data capture, and so forth.
I also want to give a shout-out to Jimeng and Kenji AI.
They do a lot of great work in this space.
Personally, I'm also very excited about
the
prospect for frontier AI to supercharge health equity.
So for example, even in the US, 85% of cancer patients are actually treated
in community center, rural hospital.
They often don't have the resource to do these kind of
matchings and so forth, and they largely preschool from the clinical trial.
But now at least the technology is already ready to level the
playing field
to actually democratizing this high-quality healthcare to everyone.
Now, obviously, the technology is just one small bit.
So it makes what impossible yesterday to become
possible tomorrow. But we still have the hard work layer
ahead of us, to rethink the workflow,
ecosystem, business model, change of management, and so forth.
So far, I've been telling you
kind of super low-hanging example of how can
we actually harness frontier AI in the text
modality to basically derive massive productivity
gain.
Now, this is in the grand scheme of things, on the other hand, is just an
appetizer.So all those clinical texts.
Actually, many of you know better than I do.
They are just highly imperfect human translation of
patient ground truth.
So over the years, I started make a lot of friends in medical folks, and they
start sharing inside joke with me.
So my radiology friend will tell me that sometime they will
actually see different thing on the same image two weeks later.
And my pathology friends tell me you can turn pathology
slide 90 degrees, sometime you see different things.
So these are some of the smartest people in the world.
But the challenge is that our visual cortex didn't
evolve in the jungle reading MRIs.
But now come the prospect of AI to potentially arm them to be
able to decipher all those really subtle kind of patterns.
And here is also a good place to insert some of the
sort of clarification about Frontier AI's capability.
So which often lead to some confusion.
So first of all, AI is no magic. So
it really sort of like data algorithm and compute.
So the Frontier AI already get to very good at
the text, including biomedical and clinical text, as we show earlier.
Partially the reason is because there is a gigantic amount of
biomedical text in the public web.
Starting from 40 million PubMed paper, you also have all the
WebMD, all the podcasts or whatever.
So that's why Frontier AI are getting very good in the text
modality. But once you go beyond the text modality.
Once you go to all those omics and imagings and so forth, there isn't
that much public data for multi-modal, longitudinal
patient journey for good reasons.
And that's actually when Frontier AI can be blind and deaf.
And that's actually exactly the exciting growth area for
us to bridging those competency gap.
Another point I want to also make is that no matter how high value a single
modality is, it's often insufficient.
So only by piece together all those modality can we
recapitulate sort of a holistic
patient journey.
So this lead us to basically start thinking about precision health
in probably a little bit nerdy way from a machine learning point of view.
So we can think about what we try to do here, is trying to learn a
function that's starting from a multi-modal input for the patient, and
we try to predict two really important medical events, disease
progression and treatment response.
Now, obviously, the challenge is that a patient journey is not a snapshot, but
actually a longitudinal time series.
Most frustratingly is that most of the information we hope to see
actually are missing. And even the observable one, they are highly biased and
highly noisy.
But this is arguably why GenAI is particularly
promising for precision health. So the Gen in the GenAI
signify generative models. So they basically describe the
probabilistic approach to try to model the joint probability
distribution of all the relevant clinical variables.
Now, it sounds like we sign up for a much harder job.
But if we can actually make even some modest degree
of progress, that means that we now have a principal way to handle all
those noise, uncertainty, biases, and so forth.
And it give us a principle too, to compress all those
observable information into this compact patient representation
and patient embedding. And also, we can now infer those
missing information using standard probabilistic inference.
That's exactly what probabilistic model do.
And then predicting the future event, it's just a special case of
inferring this missing information.
So this motivate us to start thinking about can we actually
really, using all those real world population scale, real world
data, try to pre-train frontier biomedical models.
Now the GenAI disruption means that for the first time ever, we can start
to imagine building this really high fidelity
world model as a digital twin to model the patient
journey.
Now, on the test time, if we have such a high fidelity virtual
patient, what it can do is that it can enable us
to do patient-like reasoning at the population scale.
So when somebody have a cancer diagnosis these days,
if they have resources, the first thing they are going to do is to get a second
opinion. But if you have this virtual patient, you can snap your finger and
immediately get a million second opinion.
You can interrogate all those most similar patient.
You can look at what have been tried, what kind of intervention have been tried on
them, what are the longitudinal outcome.
And you can immediately improve the patient care.
And then on the flip side, you can compare the non-responder versus the
exceptional responder and start to uncover, for example, why those
80% of patients don't respond to immunotherapy.
So even the best doctor cannot internalize a billion
patients' journey, but we can now potentially have
AI to empower them to do exactly that.
So this is a very exciting prospect, but obviously
the forward path is
anything but easy. So one of the fundamental
challenges, as many of you know, in AI, one of the really
powerful tool in machine learning is called supervised learning.
And one of the major bottleneck there is that you have to carefully curate all
this kind of example input-output pairs.
So again, AI is no magic. You need to teach the AI to do stuff,
and you need to show them how to do those thing.
And now this kind of so-called supervised training data become your major
bottleneck. So you can think about our entire
15 years of research program is trying to figure out whether we can leverage
some data that already
readily available and then try to make it as little as
possible to curate those super precious
training data. So I basically liken that to having a
free lunch. So in the rest of my talk, I will basically give you four
recipe for free lunch.So the first free lunch actually
come from all those unannotated data point themselves.
So any moment you get unannotated images, protein
sequence, and what have you, that's precious, actually,
self-supervised training instance.
So you can actually basically turn it around to basically teach the AI
to do stuff. So one very powerful general scheme
is basically this sort of encoder-decoder framework.
So you can think about really a majority of machine learning
and AI is just a glorified dimension reduction.
Because once you can actually, for example, reduce let's say a billion
dimension digital pathology slide to a 500 dimension
vector, then actually learning how to make sense of those
pathology slide will become much, much easier.
But the challenge is how do we do this dimension reduction, right?
And familiar PCA, they only can get rid
of the linear dependency. And now the promise with
deep learning is that actually you can get rid of arbitrary-- You can model and get
rid of arbitrary non-linear dependencies.
And so again, back to the encoder-decoder framework.
So you basically introduce a pair, modality-specific pair
of encoder and decoder. The encoder do the dimension reduction.
But you also want to make sure that you don't encode arbitrary crap.
So that's what the decoder come in, forcing it to be able to try to
reconstruct the input as accurately as possible.
So now you can ensure that the representation you learn
actually capture as much of the original structure and
insight as much as possible.
So
on the text modality is very, very special.
So somebody already poured billions and billions of dollar.
So I highly recommend reframing from tampering with
it until you know what you're doing.
But the good news is that you can start from all those very powerful
frontier model on the text modality.
So we can separate the two regime. So this is a
very powerful paradigm, but in a specific
modality in biomedicine, there are also a lot of
idiosyncratic challenges. So go back to solve the tumor
microenvironment. So, obviously one of the holy grail would
be that can we figure out, uncover this tumor microenvironment grammar
between tumor cell, immune cells, stromal elements, and so forth, and
then
really unraveling all the secrets there.
So
in theory, we actually have exactly the right tool from AI to do this.
So many of you probably familiar with Transformer, which is a workhorse of
modern gen AI. And for images, so Transformer
actually, the way that it works is actually really simple.
So you're given a image. Basically what Transformer do is to try
to pass messages between every
pair of the pixel.
And then you heard about all those deep learning, many layers and so forth.
They basically facilitate message passing for many rounds.
So after you do that, every pixel actually know everything about every
other pixel. And this is exactly why Transformer can be so flexible,
so powerful in modeling arbitrary kind of
interdependencies. But
this superpower actually come with one big Achilles heel.
In order to do the pairwise message passing, that means that your computation will
scale quadratically in the input size.
And unfortunately, digital pathology is some of the largest image in the world.
So a single
standard pathology slide, if you do a standard Transformer, it will cost
you a billion times of compute compared to your favorite cats and dog web
images.
So here, basically what we try to do is to steal one idea that
originate from speech recognition, which also have to deal with this kind of long
context, and then adapt that to medical imaging space.
So the idea is this is called dilated attention.
The idea is actually very simple. So think about
the pairwise message passing. If you have a local
neighborhood, very small input, it doesn't actually cause you too much trouble.
You can definitely do that. So after you do that, then every
pixel actually know the neighbor very well already.
Now the quadratic start to kill you when you try to pass message between your
local neighborhood and some neighborhood very far away.
But if every pixel already know the local neighbor very well, that means that
you can just elect representative for every neighborhood, and then
focusing message passing among the representative.
So this basically give you a principle way that you can actually turn the knob
to essentially dramatically cut down the computation, but
still try to maximally preserve the fidelity of the computation.
So we actually adapt this to digital pathology.
We have some really, really wonderful collaborator
from Providence and University of Washington.
I also want to highlight Bernie, Ram, and Brian
sitting in the front row.
So we are very excited to basically develop this Giga-Path
model that is the first pathology foundation model that can truly
scale Transformer to the gigapixel whole slide images.
So one of the things that we actually set out to do is that we try to
throw all kinds of hard problem to it.
And then in particular, we try to look at can we train
sort of a pan-cancer signature across 41 cancer types.
And to actually correlate H&E images
with some of the biomarkers. So, initially it sound a
little bit crazy because those 41 cancer type have very, very different
morphology. But the good news about AI is it never
complain. So you can throw anything to them.
And indeed, we find some pretty interesting signals.
And then, my friend, Gabrielle, actually sitting there,
he has been leading this very amazing project at
Mount Sinai and Memorial Sloan Kettering that actually demonstrate
in a global prospective trial that you can actually take this idea
and turn it into kind of real world deployment.
So in particular, what they observe is that even in the US,
despite strong guideline-A quarter of the lung cancer patients
never get EGFR
mutation status sequence before the first line, largely due to resource
constraint. So that means that their treatment likely is suboptimal.
And what they actually show is that they can actually just fine-tune the gigabyte
model and then predict those EGFR mutation
status just the moment you get that tissue sample and take the
microscopic image, you can make that prediction,
and amazingly with very high accuracy.
So very excited to see this kind of real-world application.
And this is one of my favorite graphs to share.
Actually, I can look at it all day because
a lot of folks that tell us their favorite applications, so
really encouraging.
So far we talk about the first free lunch.
Now imagining tomorrow you wake up, you already train,
everybody already train
amazing foundation model for each modality.
But our job is far from being done. Because there is no
guarantee that those semantic space uncovered by each individual
modality will actually align with each other.
So in this sense, each of those modalities is like a distinct language.
So the CT could be a French, the digital pathology could be a
Hindu. And very soon we will have a United Nation problem here.
So in actual united nation, in actual translation,
what people do is that they actually introduce this
resource-rich language, typically English, and using it to serve
as this so-called interlingual.
Basically as a bridge across all those hundreds of languages.
So for example, you may not have any parallel data between two language
A and B. So thereby in conventional supervised machine learning
paradigm, you cannot do any translation.
But with the interlingual as a mediator, you can potentially translate language
from A to English and then from English to B.
So this is actually exactly how commercial translation engines scale to
hundreds of language in the world.
So what we are proposing is to let's steal that playbook and apply that to
multimodal
reasoning in biomedicine. And obviously the very obvious
interlingual modality is text. We already have very powerful
frontier model. And for the text modality.
Moreover, for any modality under the sun, the study of that modality,
often you leave some paper trail. So for example, when you have radiology
images, you often have a radiology report.
For pathology slide, you sometimes have pathology report.
So those are become your free lunch.
So we can reusing the encoder and decoder portraying the first stage
and then focus all our computation trying to train this very lightweight
adapter or translator, to ground the
modality from individual modality to the text semantic space.
You can do this modularly for individual modality.
And after you do that, number one,
all those semantic space will now suddenly get much closer to each other.
And also the second
implication is that those frontier model, keep in mind, they read every single
published paper and every single comments in the web.
So they have incredible
capture of knowledge,
the current consensus knowledge, and also
incredible reasoning capability.
So now by actually aligning individual modality to the text semantic space,
you basically get for free using the
frontier model as a unified knowledge representation and
reasoner to reason across all those modality to actually
interpret individual modality. In the interest of time, I wouldn't
go into too much detail. If you are interested, you can check out some of our
early work in LLaVA-Med that basically provide the first general recipe for
how to do this in biomedicine.
Since then, we have extended, we have demonstrated in multiple
domains like radiology. Other folks have applied it to digital
pathologies and so forth. And, more recently,
we applied this paradigm to actually train this model
called BioMedParse that basically is the
dream for a lazy person like me. So to basically just talk to the
image, and then have it to do the holistic image
analysis. So BioMedParse can basically
capture nine major image modality,
64 major object types.
Originally, we actually
use a title, "Segmenting Everything Everywhere All at Once."
So after the Oscar movie, unfortunately the Nature Method
editor think this is too sensational, so we have to go back to a much more
boring title.
But the editor still feel quite excited about the paper,
so she also published an independent review paired with the publication of
the paper and say some very encouraging words.
And as usual, the most exciting prospect is to see actually people
try to use it and find some of it useful.
So far we talk about the first two free lunch.
These are based on modality that relatively abundant and frequent.
Unfortunately in biomedicine, or maybe fortunately, is that we actually
have a long tail of emerging super high value
modality.
And that basically expand our potential scope
for uncovering the secret in biomedicine.
But for those long tail modality,
oftentimes we don't get that many data point, let alone any
text accompanying them.
So for example, spatial omics. In
particular, something like multiplex immunofluorescence.
They basically can give you
simultaneously map out multiple protein
activation status in individual cells.
So they basically give you a very detailed digital map
about the tumor microenvironment grammar.Now, there is only one
catch, right? So they are very costly and expensive, and
time-consuming to generate.
So generating the data, for even just a single tissue
for even the top labs like our collaborator at Providence
can take days and cost thousands of dollars.
And now you can do the math and imagine what if we want to generate the data for
every single person in the globe, right? That will bankrupt the humanity.
So in collaboration, again, with our Providence collaborators
and University of Washington, we developed this multi-model AI called
GigaTime. So basically what they try to do is to start from
a Rosetta Stone of 40 million cells with pair H&E and also
the spatial proteomics, the MIF.
And then we try to learn a translator to go from the dirt
cheap pathology slide
to actually the very hard-to-get spatial proteomics.
So our Providence collaborator generate this super precious, the first
batch of this kind of Rosetta Stone.
And then we basically try to teach the AI to learn from
the correlation there. So here in this example, you can see in the middle
column, that's the ground true
MIF. And then on the right-hand side, those are the
kind of AI-simulated MIF. Now obviously, again, AI is no
magic. We will not get to perfect anytime soon, and
is highly varied by the protein channel.
But as you can see, amazingly, just from such a relatively
small training set,
and
essentially just the first attempt, we were able to already
reconstitute
a ballpark of the information in the spatial site.
So some of you might ask, how can this be possible, right?
Again, AI is no magic. So there is no magic behind. What is going on?
So how can you start from essentially H&E basically give you
nucleus and cytoplasm, basically the morphology, how can you actually get
to the cell state?
So it turns out that actually this is related to an idea that
almost date back to the dawn of AI and linguistic.
So, I was originally training as a AI NLP
person. So this is something that basically, at the time,
every NLP people talk about, is so-called distributional
hypothesis. So imagining tomorrow you receive in your
email a big chunk of Martian text, right?
So you don't understand every single word in it.
But what you observe is that you have these two word, A and B.
And they often appear in the context nearby words that are actually
the same. So the distribution hypothesis then basically
hypothesize that those two word probably have related meaning.
So sometime they could be synonyms, sometime they could be acronym.
So in fact, a big part of our early days, NLP,
was actually using this idea as inductive
biases to basically cluster words and
so forth.
What's actually really exciting, and that's by the way, also lead to the
so-called word embedding. So otherwise, why would it make sense to predict
next word from the previous word? This also lead to ultimately
the language model, the LM, and all the gen AI first.
But fundamentally, it originate from this idea.
And turns out that what's really amazing here is that this idea seem to
also be applicable to cell biology.
In particular, when you think about a T cell, whether
it's active or exhausted, just by morphology alone,
it's very hard to tell. But active T cell often
appear obviously in supportive environment, and
exhausted T cell often appear in highly regulated environment.
So thereby, even if you can just barely make out the core
cell type in the surrounding environment, it can already give you some hints
about whether the cell, what kind of state it's in.
Now, obviously, just like distribution hypothesis is not far from perfect
in the text front.
It's far from perfect in the cell biology front, but still,
that can already give you some signal.
And, so that's kind of like what's the secret behind
the scene.
So with our Providence collaborator, we apply GigaTime to
14,000 cancer patient, essentially as the first populations
experiment. And then we basically run GigaTime on all
the available H&E pathology slide and generate
over 300,000 virtual MIF size. Now,
that basically give us essentially sort of like
a way to conduct really the largest spatial proteomics study
that were previously completely unthinkable.
So we can basically looking at all those kind of cell states in the tumor
microenvironment and correlate with the longitudinal outcome you care about, the
progression, tumor response, and so forth.
So that really solve the-- I would say, GigaTime obviously
is exciting first step, but it's just a baby, tiny, tiny baby
step, and there was a gazillion way we can improve.
So finally, in case you are not completely full yet, so let me present you
the final, but arguably the most important free lunch, which is the
patient journey themself. So many of you are probably familiar with
GPT-4. It basically learn by predict next word, next word, next word.
Now it turns out that we can actually try to do the same thing for virtual
patient. What if we can serialize the patient journey and try to
predict next event, next event, next event?
Now just like in the language model form, if you do this in a
small scale, nothing much happen.
But what if you can do this at eight billion patients' journey?
Then there was this whole notion about emerging
capability in the larger language model world.
Basically saying that if you have large capacity in that model, you pre-train
on large enough data, they can actually uncover a lot of sort of
insight and intelligence that you--
It's sort of like undergone a phase transition that suddenly those
capabilities start to seem to be emerging and become very,
very high competency.So as
a tiny baby step, we team up with Epic and Yale pre-train
this
foundation model for virtual patient called Curiosity.
And this is
built on top of the amazing work that Epic folks and the Cosmos
community have done with 300 million
patient journey, right?
So essentially, we train the largest virtual patient model with one billion
parameter for the model, pre-training on over 100 billion
medical events, very fine-grained medical events, right?
Fine-grained diagnostic,
medication, procedural, lab, and values.
It took over 40,000 GPU hours. Now, of course
this kind of large-scale pre-training require lots
of resources, right? So we can't go to the senior leadership on both sides to say,
"Hey, give us lots of money and do a lot of trial and error." So one of the
important exercises that we have to do is to conduct this so-called
scaling law study. Basically, what it gives you is two
things. You basically establish a best practice, right?
So to actually search among all those...
A lot of black art in gen AI is to figure out the
hyperparameters, right? So there was a laboring of a gazillion
hyperparameters, and actually doing those,
tuning them actually accurately would make a huge difference.
And this kind of scaling law basically is using small pre-training
run, right, on small data, smaller model, to basically figure out
the best practice to do that. Another thing is to using that to
establish empirical laws to actually extrapolate, like what if
we can scale this up to next order of magnitude, 10x larger,
100x larger?
Can we actually get
exponential ROI, or do I
get diminishing return, right? So, again, in the
language model world, right? That's exactly how
the early GPT model were using this kind of study to
justify why we should spend a billion dollars to train the next
generation. And here we obviously do a much smaller scale
for structure EHRs.
One of the amazing thing for this kind of solve generative model is
that it can basically conduct a very
generic pre-training. And it try to capture as
much as the correlation structure as possible in the patient journey, right?
And then out of the box, it can actually perform lots and lots of different things
that are not specifically
designed for, right? So, for example, Epic folks have
actually
painstakingly curated 78 tasks for evaluation.
They also trained supervised method for each individual task.
Now, what we did is that we take the Curiosity model out of the box,
just do this brain death simulation for the future, right?
You can simulate as long as you want.
You can simulate as many parallel universe as you want to start quantifying the
uncertainty. And amazingly, out-of-the-box, this model, a
single model, actually match or outperform those supervised method
in 78 real-world clinical tasks.
So again, there are gazillion of way to improve, right?
But this is really a very promising first step.
And Epic actually is getting very
excited, and the whole Cosmos community start rolling
out this model to the Cosmos community.
So I want to conclude by adding one major caveat, right?
So,
this is one of the key reason why RCT is not going away anytime soon, right?
the real-world patient journey, they are free lunch, right?
But there is a reason why they are not Michelin three-star restaurant yet, right?
And one of the big problem is that these are observational data, right?
So it's subject to confoundings. Now, obviously, this is
also an area where actually AI can potentially also provide you
with a potentially much more powerful way to model those
underlying distribution, to model those potential unknown confounders,
right? To basically go way beyond, for example, some of the standard tool,
like propensity scoring and so forth.
So, basically, hopefully, I give you sort of three things, right?
Microscope, crystal ball, and wind tunnel.
That's some of the area that AI could potentially contribute.
So I'm really looking forward to picking of your brains.
And I want to highlight my team at Microsoft Research and
they do all the real work.
And also all our amazing collaborator without whom we can't obviously do
any of this.
So thanks very much, and we should have some time for
questions.
For anyone with question, feel free to come to the mic.
Thank you for a fantastic talk. This is Mohammed Gadamosi from the University of
Florida, College of Pharmacy.
I'm quite interested in
using generative AI to predict the next event, but
maybe on a smaller scale than the patient.
I think there's a huge interest in the evolution of a tumor, maybe in
response to a particular therapeutic.
And there's a lot of methods that are currently out there.
Some people have used agent-based modeling to achieve this goal.
I haven't seen a lot in the realm of generative AI.
Could you maybe comment on the ability of generative AI to achieve that
outcome and maybe compare it to standard methods that are utilized
now, like agent-based modeling?
Mm-hmm.
What's the trade-off there? I think there may be some challenges with
interpretability-
Yep
... with generative AI that agent-based modeling may not face.
Yeah, absolutely. That's a wonderful question.
You will notice I barely mentioned agent, even though that's kind of like
today's buzzword, just like big data once upon a time is,
right?Agent is a very, very powerful paradigm,
but I would say agent is kind of orthogonal to a lot of this kind of
modeling. So agent, agentic AI, actually, you can think about
the trial scope that I mentioned in the first example, right?
That's basically one embodiment of what agentic AI can
do. So essentially,
you have lots and lots of tasks. Right now, you have to manually do them, right?
What agentic AI actually is to
decompose those tasks and be able to carry them out.
Now, this is nothing new. So if you look up agentic AI or
distributed computing and so forth, it dates back decades.
What's
new today is that this frontier model become very powerful
in terms of being able to understand natural language instruction.
So that's the first very important part.
In the old days, you have to actually specify in
domain-specific language to specify, "Here's what I want to
do. Here's how you should plan, here's how you should execute," and so
forth. But now you can actually just say it in natural language.
Another thing that some of the frontier AI unlock is that in
capturing a lot of those knowledge.
So for example,
actually, AI can go through all those 30 million paper, identify all the
possible experimental setting, what are all the procedures and so forth,
which traditionally are very hard to do manually, right?
So all those are basically the way.
And then agentic, obviously the
ultimate goal is can we do this kind of science in the loop, right?
So sort of really facilitate, okay, given the...
Let's come up with hypotheses, let's actually then execute it.
Let's look at the result. Let's go back to revise our hypothesis and so
forth. So again, agentic AI, I would say, is orthogonal.
It's basically taking any sort of digital knowledge work, and now you can have
a very intelligent, very powerful,
completely untiring assistant to do...
You can control a million assistant to help you do it, right?
So, that's the agentic part. But the modeling part is still sort
of challenging. How do you actually model the temporal kind of
dependency, the temporal dynamics?
That's not like you just out your agentic AI, it will solve the problem.
Because a lot of those modalities and so forth are not
actually available, again, in the public web, right?
And your data point may be very few.
And so the standards of the image encoding or any of those
encoding may not be very good for this kind of data, right?
So I would say,
as you can see in sort of
a lot of this kind of paradigm, what we try to do is to
find places where you have abundant data, and then
using that-- Again, 99% of the underlying work is just doing dimension
reduction. Then once you do that, then you're actually using
mobilize, your very precious small data to
building on top of this already very well-learned representation.
Then you can actually sort of do the modeling much better.
And then agentic basically take away all the manual step, but it's completely
orthogonal, I would say.
I see. One follow-up to that. In terms
of predicting tumor evolution,
we may not have a lot of images. I agree with you, the data is quite
sparse in that regard. But there is a lot of natural language that is
out there. A lot of people have written reviews on how therapy
affects tumor growth and-
Yeah.
-affects the pushes towards a hot tumor or pushes
towards a cold tumor.
Yep.
Is it possible to leverage that information in an AI
model that would be able to predict tumor evolution in response to
therapy?
Absolutely. If you see the free lunch, right?
So they basically, again, come from the places where you have abundant data.
One abundant data source is basically all the knowledge, right?
Basically, all the healthcare common sense is captured by all those frontier
models. You can ask it everything about all the published guidelines and knowledge
base and so forth. All the experimental settings and so forth.
Of course, you need some guardrail to shape them, but fundamentally, the
information are in those one trillion models.
And then another kind of source of information is all those
images, they actually have related images.
So you can also get a lot of those related image.
For example, that's how, for example, Gabriele and team build on
using the gigapath to actually model sort of pathology
slide. They are using in just specific kind of
scenario that are very different from even the original
provenance data, but they can show that actually because of this
pre-training, because of the dimension reduction,
that already is a very good representation.
So those would be probably two obvious kind of starting point.
Absolutely. Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Thanks. Maybe over there. Yeah.
So Mike Saracci, Boston G.
On one of your last slides, you went through
some unexpected predictions of events you didn't
necessarily train for. And one of the things you said
really caught my ear, which was that you
allow for the simulation of an unlimited number of
universes in order to
help the model understand how precise it was.
So what that has me thinking about, the question that
is pervasive for me is, as we move into an era where we're going to be
running these virtual trials,
what's the right way in each of those instances
to estimate and then communicate the precision with which the
result is going to be representative of what the reality,
biological reality is going to be?
I'm sure this is something you've thought through, could you talk through
where you think that portion of the field should go?
Because I know the way that we communicate that precision is going to
have to be fairly standard across-
Yeah. Absolutely. So great question.
Just to repeat the question for the online audience.
So I think that what you're asking is,
given this virtual patient, obviously the Holy Grail would be to simulate the
future trajectory. You can also simulate many, many parallel universe, right?
But how do we do this virtual trial if we want
to really kind of turn that into sort of the standard to advancing
next generation medicine? Is that kind of the gist of your question?
Yes. And importantly, how do we communicate how
accurate the answer that we generate in silico
is?
Yeah, absolutely. So, I would say that,
again, AI is no magic, so I wouldn't say AI actually fundamentally change how
evidence-based medicine works, right?
We still try to figure out the causality, like if we do this kind of
intervention, what might happen to the patient, right?
So given this intervention, what will be the status
change? So I would say a lot of the
frameworks and so forth, I would say is still kind of applicable
in my mind. But I think what AI can do is probably
three or four dimensions. One is that it can take away a
lot of the
mundane chores work, right, and then start to make them
much, much efficient and faster.
The other one is the
other
aspect to your point about the accuracy is that we need to
avoid being kidding ourself, right?
Because one of the challenge is the confounders, right?
If the virtual case arm and the virtual control arm fundamentally are
very different in some of the aspect that might influence the treatment response,
then we are host, right? So, but here again,
you can think about propensity scoring is one kind of poor man's
approach where you model just a few features.
But with this kind of more all-encompassing virtual patient, you
can start to using that to replace some of those kind of
limited representation. And we now no longer need to worry
that much about we missing a lot of the unknown
confounders, right? Basically, you try to incorporate every single aspect of it.
And
then another kind of potential prospect is we can start to
model potentially much longer longitudinal scale, like you
can sort of virtually simulate. Now, get back to your accuracy.
I would actually argue that a lot of the gold standards still
remain, right? So we probably, at the end of the day, still need to run
some of the maybe much smaller, much more faster kind of RCT,
right? So looking at
the actual outcome with the intervention.
But what AI can basically is hugely leveraging all those real
launch, all those real-world journey to hugely magnify the
value you can draw from those
small set of examples. Another aspect I want to add is
right now, if you look at how clinical trial conducted, right?
We say, "Oh, we need to add this condition.
We need to add that condition." Very soon you are left with no patient, right?
And we also know how all those condition comorbidity actually
intertwine. So, the hope is also that can we actually
be able to model all those together.
Now, one of the caveat obviously, is that this is a high dimension model, right?
So many people call it black box and so forth.
So you no longer have the comfort zone to say this is just reduced to
some simple rules, right? Like A go to B and so forth.
So that is indeed a potential challenge, but I would say it
partially is because biomedicine is very complex, right?
So does that answer your question? Sorry.
Not completely, but it was fantastic. Thank you. Maybe I can follow up.
Yeah. Love to. Yeah.
Yeah.
Hello, this is George Aquara. I'm from Scripps Research.
I wanted to ask a question regarding, well, we'll see all these
foundation models that you have built,
which is fantastic on how we can learn from unsupervised,
less labeled data and so on. I want to have a little bit more details
on two aspects. One is, so are all these model
after they are trained,
are they public or will they become public at certain point?
And also, seems to me that they are all based on public data.
If I understand, is there any concern also on the privacy
potentially or
can they reveal something or potentially re-identify in an
unexpected way participants and
create some problems in that respect? So...
Yeah, absolutely. So I would say privacy and compliance is obviously our
most important aspect for the patient, right?
So,
I will also highlight another potential risk is that
when a virtual patient get really, really good, right?
Imagining you have a better and better crystal ball, right?
On one hand, you can use it for precision health.
On the other hand, it
could also be used to deny your claim, right?
So,
I would say basically what we are trying to do is to de-risk this
technological approach to say, what can AI possibly do with
this kind of data, with this kind of algorithm, with this kind of compute, right?
But I would say there is a larger societal problem.
Question is like, how should we think about
this new era when AI is much, much more powerful compared to
prior statistics and supervised machine learning methods,
right? So, and exactly to a point, there were some of
the traditional risks that will be very small.
Just like for example, in the past, even if you have some public information,
without a search engine, somebody would never find it, right?
Now, with a search engine, every single piece of information you cannot escape,
right? So, there is a risk and challenges
here, and the question is how with the society to do that.
Now, back to some of our immediate work, we have a tradition
try to--
because we already take all those compute, take a lot of expertise, take a
lot of to do train those model which-As long as
possible, we try to make them openly available, right?
Now, some of them, I would say they are not trained on public data.
For example, our joint work with Providence on the GigaPath,
GigaTime.
But we carefully want to make sure that the model they
release are only on those unannotated
images without any PHIs and so forth.
So we want to make sure we minimize risk.
And also the whole release
process, we try to put it in a controlled way.
But again, I would say that beyond that, we are just a small
potato in the big cap community. I would say it ultimately
will take regulators, payers, and the whole society to figure out
how should we rethink about how we regulate this, how we actually go about
this, right? Because there are tremendous good we can do, but there is also
tremendous risk that we have to be aware of.
Thank you.
Yeah. Thanks.
Yes. My question is really sort of in line with that question.
I've always been told there's no such thing as a free lunch.
Just because you're feeding one to me, I shouldn't necessarily eat it.
So with curiosity-- Sorry, this mic is really small.
For curiosity,
I'm concerned. I'm Canadian. We're in a public healthcare system.
I lived in the US for many years in an insurance-based provider.
Is there concerns that insurance could just take this, make
some sort of very conservative or not conservative version of this model, and then
start denying people care? And is that something that you guys have talked about,
and whether or not this is really a path you should be going down with-
Mm-hmm
...
given the constraints of hallucinating and
predicting things in the context of this type of a large model?
Yeah. You actually packed several good questions there.
So let me gradually unpack. The first thing, I'm a machine learning guy by
training, right? So there is this machine learning 101, it's called no
free lunch theorem, right? So
basically, it's like any learning is only possible with some inductive
biases, right? So
when I say free lunch, I'm more talking about from a sort of like a
techno business front, right? It's basically like in order
to directly generate those kind of data for the purpose of
training the model that you want, it's pretty much economically
infeasible, or maybe nobody would do that, right?
But the free lunch there is you already have some other related data.
Again, not directly the high-quality data you would like to have,
but some other related data. And if you can put some of the
smartness to connect those two modalities together and leveraging
those information source, right?
By leveraging AI to pull out those information,
then you can using that to generate a lot of the new signal that
power your original application. So that's what I mean by free lunch, right?
Now, I think your question specifically to curiosity, I think there are
several different questions, right?
So the first question is actually more related to Giorgio's question,
which is how should we think about using this
responsibly? So this is absolutely sort of the top priority that for
Epic Cosmos and us, right? So, many of you are probably familiar with Epic
Cosmos, right? So they are actually governing by this 300 health system
that form this consortium. So every single thing, both the data and
the model, and also all the compute, are happening within that
tenant. So we actually don't get any data outside.
Just like when we work with Providence, right?
We don't get any data to outside. We work with our
partner inside their private tenant, and then to conduct the computation
and everything. So at that level, we make sure that all those computation
are actually within their control and governance, right?
And then, the Epic Cosmos work by essentially governed by
this
Epic Cosmos governing council, and it's for research
only.
And so the model is basically now releasing
to all the Cosmos participants and so forth, right?
So it's really that consortium are governing how they do it,
and certainly something that you talk about is absolutely some of the really
important top of mind. I would say the last aspect you raised is also a very good
question, which is the real-world patient journey
again, mix up lots and lots of confounders, right?
So a lot of the coding, ICD coding, right, obviously, it's a
well-known
thing. It's like they may not absolutely reflecting the diagnostic,
right? And then there is a lot of idiosyncratic
healthcare practice challenges and so forth.
So once again, I'm not claiming magic here.
Far from it, right? So what we try to do is even starting from
sort of relatively straightforward sort of today's technology,
what kind of insight can we unveil from those kind of data?
What can we already be able to do? The next question is,
how do we, number one, scientifically, how do we counter a lot of
those confounders and so forth? And then societally, how do we
actually-- now that this capability is we demonstrate that this is possible,
how should we collectively think about how to regulate it?
So at least that's my naive sort of two cents for
now.
Hey, thank you. Great session. I'm Amitai
Jacob from AstraZeneca. I have a little bit maybe sort
of a more technical question, but I think that can serve the community.
So if you look at the left, we have all the modalities, and if we just
from the last few days,
two, I think, amazing paper, one on a new RNA
foundation model called Authoris from Bo Wang,
and another from
Goodfellow, that is-On the DNA mutation?
Yep.
Right. And I guess that next week we're going to have more. Right?
I'm wondering, and I think you guys in Microsoft have a lot of
technical capabilities to help the
community understand how these kind of newer presentations can be
plugged in and show the deltas.
Mm-hmm.
That could serve many, including AstraZeneca.
So I was wondering if you've been thinking about that on the strategy
side, on the technical side, and how,
as a big tech, you could maybe lead or-
Mm-hmm
... share with us your thoughts around that.
Yeah. That's a fantastic question and
certainly something we should chat more about offline. Right?
But I would say that if I think about what will be
some of the wave for disruption for GenAI to start going
to cancer research, but also more broadly, biomedical discovery, right?
I would say the first wave is already going on.
So I call it productivity gain. Now, obviously, everybody talk
about agentic AI, right? And that's indeed
where the first wave will be agentic AI, right?
So this, again, anything you can think of today that you
can just describe to some intelligent intern, right?
That you have, and to be able to do. Now, obviously,
anything you could manipulate on the file systems or
anything, your VM, your cloud computings and everything, this
agent can do it for you. Right? So
in the past, you have to painstakingly do a lot of
those kind of groundwork. But actually now,
having this kind of agentic AI system can already do it very, very well.
Now, Claude already show how this can be do for empowering the
programmer,
or replacing some of the jobs, right?
So the question is, can we also
tailor-make that for the biomedical discovery process to
really empower the scientists, right?
To actually, right now you might have to waste
hours or days or weeks to do some of the really, really boring stuff.
But now you can free them up, right?
So maybe replacing the boring part of the job, but now free them up to do
the way more pleasant and the creative part of the work.
So I would say that is absolutely a platform question,
exactly like you said. And really, I would
say, again, certainly some of the
technology
company can deal with some of the scale problem.
But I would also say the stakeholder, like you guys, who actually are in the
trench, who know what are the important things.
I will flag one important aspect is the benchmark.
Again, AI is no magic, right? So
if we don't know how to hold them accountable, then it's very hard to
evaluate progress and so forth. And that's actually how I imagine some of
the key stakeholder, end-to-end stakeholder like you guys can come up with those
kind of benchmarking. And then the potential platform provider
can actually then-- Once you have a goalpost,
it's not hard for the AI folks to actually engineer it to
actually get to those goalposts.
Then I think we can start to think about the more exciting
part beyond the agentic wave, right?
So to say, how can we not just do a shallow, like tool
use, a plug-in kind of use, right, of the model?
How can we truly actually
integrate all the insight captured by this model?
Right now, the amazing thing is that there are, like you said, there are so many of
this model. Each of them reflect one small piece of the universe, one piece
of the silo, right? Can we have a sort of unified medical
brain that capture all those? That will also be-
This was actually my next question.
Your thoughts about moving from a
late fusion-
Mm-hmm
... or
feeding multimodal embeddings in a
late fusion-
Yeah
... versus one big beautiful model.
Yeah.
I think my opinion is that we are on a journey.
And in the end, we're going to have a one world model for patients, right?
But then what's your thoughts about this journey and the-
Yeah. This is a question actually we have debated even with our own
CEO three years ago, right? So
I would say that it's probably one-- What I mean
by one, it's more like one system
that actually can capture all this kind of knowledge and insight,
right? But just like think about me, right? Standing here.
I'm actually a number of trillion of cells, right?
So with different kind of organs and...
So actually look under the hood. There are so many kind of
underlying kind of components, right?
But still, hopefully, I function like a
coherent human being, right? So I would think about that actually is
where we want to get to. It's
a unifying system that actually are coherent and
consistent
in terms of the goals and everything.
But underneath it, there could be lots of kind of like components.
The reason we would try to do late fusion, there are several reasons for that.
Number one is that it's very, very hard to fine-tune those
humongous foundation model, right?
Like now MiFauns probably 10 trillion parameter, right?
You really need to know what you're doing to do fine-tuning.
And also oftentimes they are training on tens of trillion of
tokens and very hard to move any needles.
On the other hand, once you go beyond the text modality, there was so
much big growth area, right? So for example, that's why with just 1
billion parameter in the Curiosity, even when we try to pre-train some
from scratch-
Mm-hmm
... for those structure EHR, actually the language
model are not very good, right? So
anything beyond the text,
there is much easier to make progress and that's why we want to try to decompose
that and do the late fusion approach.
But obviously nothing is completely set in
stone, right? I would say right now we are still very early.
So
again, go back to the original goalpost.
What are the hard problem? And that will be my default
approach.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Awesome. Thank you very much.
Sorry this dragged on a little bit late, but thanks for everyone who attended the
session. This concludes the session. Thank you very much.